wow afghanistan has one of the highest
concentrations of landmines in the world
ever since the soviet invasion in 1979
land mines have become synonymous with
the country
something that is not likely to change
anytime soon that depends us on me
it has been 15 years since i lost my
legs in a landmine explosion i was seven
years old and didn't know what a
landmine was
i stepped on one and lost both my
legs i was at the border between iran
and afghanistan i didn't know how to
look out for landmines so i accidentally
stepped on one the landmine exploded and
i lost one of my legs
used by all sides in every modern war
fought on afghan soil the work to rid
the country of landmines seems endless
so an integral part of our work on
humanitarian demining is actually
educating adults children
on the risks and how to avoid them how
can they recognize
the ordinances and unexploded organizers
and and and landmines how are they going
to
react if they find things in the
at the surface that they don't
recognize
the international community isolated the
taliban government after the fall of
kabul last year limiting much-needed
humanitarian assistance
hardest hit the afghan people
the poorest suffer most and aid groups
warn more afghans slide into poverty
every day
decades of war 20 years of u.s
occupation and a return to taliban rule
in afghanistan the future mirrors the
past
a legacy of lost limbs
for a new generation
zayn basravi al-jazeera